um Pat action I have this weird thing
where I need someone to say action if is
that from MK Ultra have I been
brainwashed in Hollywood no you're like
a real Showbiz person like I'm like a
show I'm like I need it's like a
pavlovian like Pavlov's dog this is like
the only place that says action now at
the writer strike so it's nice yeah yeah
I mean what's that the writer's truck
yeah I mean I don't know how's that I
feel like this is as an actor let me uh
no I I don't know it looks better it's
never gonna end yeah if you think so
there's just like not a lot I mean as
two people doing podcasts which more
people listen to we're like oh God
movies are in TV are going away how did
that happen like we did this we made
sure it happens yeah I think we all felt
like ignored by the industry so like
we'll do like not ignore it in one way
or another right where it's like we have
to go make this we have to do that or
you can make a certain thing you guys
shouldn't have rejected us yeah yeah
that was a bad move on your part you
know but then there's like are we on air
right now yeah oh okay on air I don't
know well you said action live industry
shark
on air well your Showbiz talk here on
film did you have you seen Oppenheimer
or Barbie or anything I haven't seen
them yet yeah did you love I liked
Oppenheimer I think Barbie's like
whatever yeah it's no it's like a well
it's beautiful looking but it's like
Barbie for brunettes is just is just
traumatic really it's just like my whole
childhood all over again like I love
that like it's amazing how it was like
the last couple years like body
positivity diversity and everything
Barbie a billion dollars people are like
I know and she's skinny hot blonde but
that was like the big that was like the
big joke in the movie the biggest laugh
line is when she's like I'm just worried
I'm not pretty and then the voiceover of
Helen Mirren comes on and she's like
Margot Robbie's probably not the right
person to make this point it's like but
you wrote that line and cast Margot
Robbie of course of course but it's just
funny that everyone was like oh thank
God a gorgeous blonde again
these Jews started taking over movies
for a while all this diversity was
killing Hollywood and they just put a
shiksa back in but he's uh no she's very
hot do you have sisters I have a sister
yeah because did she have Barbies
she was so much older than me I don't
think she had uh Barbies though okay as
far as I remember so the brunette Barbie
She's a redhead my sister oh really do
you know what the name of the redhead
Barbie is uh canceled I don't know what
was the name sunburned is that really oh
okay so Barbie is the hot blonde sure
and then everyone was you know whatever
there was always like a push for diverse
days my guess I'm sure mom's in the 70s
were like we need other ones diversity
back in the day is it ready yeah that's
amazing freckles diversity higher Irish
you know ethnic
um Irish Barbie she's just really sad
and swamped over a toilet that's the
most depressing horizontal
um she's wobbly when she tries to walk
um so the brunette's name is Skipper
okay as in like skip her wow holy shit
I'm not maybe maybe it's just like
Skipper like the brunette like what you
name the doll Barbies like Barbie and
then there's like Skipper Barbie's
interests were like Malibu Corvette
sunbathing bikinis Skipper's interest on
the box were technology
technology well she'd be doing better
now now it's she has a photo blog she
enjoys uploading photos to her photo
blog have you ever heard a lonelier
sentence and then the red comes with a
cat and a diary yeah damn brutal and an
egg freezing kid
and like a Plenty of Fish profile like
it's bad plenty of fish is old school
very old school did you ever do that one
no but I was uh in New Orleans or
something recently performing and I said
like what dating app did you meet on and
someone said POF and I was like what's
that one and it was like plenty of like
it's still around yeah and they just use
the acronym it's too sad a name yeah
it's also like you're saying what people
say when people break up there's plenty
of fish in the city yes that's like made
for loneliness and the whole thing is
that pussies smell like fish like it's
always felt like I love Seafood a lot of
smelly that's a weird insult that a
pussy smells like fish because because
it depends the kind of fish it should be
more specific like a nice sea bream I'm
not into a Briny
really meal I love a brownie you're like
an oysty oyster guy I do oysters I'll
get in there too really yeah I love it
oh he's pussy I can die that's like
whenever I see a guy eat oysters I'm
like that guy goes hard for sure yay
sometimes you say that to them at the
bar too right
you can put a little lemon on it but I
do need to understand I don't think
oysters taste good they make me gag do
you have to start early
or do you just have to Hate Yourself no
I mean I didn't eat them young I think I
was just like let's roll the dice for
the price you think that's a flavor
that's acceptable no we're such idiots
too I was with Gary veterans who I bring
on the road and and we're in Buffalo and
Gary had the bright idea to get takeout
oysters sent to the club and I was like
are you a fucking idiot and then he goes
oh come on dude it's fine and he takes
one and then once once you see someone
else do it you're like well I'm not
gonna let you go down alone so I had the
oysters take out too they're just
sitting around no so you die no that's
why you don't take out oysters and we're
both just belching on stage it's one of
those things
we were so lucky we didn't get ill but
isn't the whole idea you don't chew it
you try to try to get it down as quickly
as possible you slurp it that I mean
they're supposed to be aphrodisiacs and
I think part of it is probably just that
the motion of that I'm sorry I did that
that was nice that was awful sorry about
that uh no but some three people just
died in New York City from oysters
really yeah there's some sort of of like
fentanyl oysters have hit New York City
what a combo that would be dude there's
more to fentanyl combos out here I had a
raccoon in my
tree and couldn't get it out and it
wasn't moving which is unusual raccoon
Behavior like poking it it's just like a
sleep I call Animal Control I'm like
which is this is so California Animal
Control I was like there's a raccoon in
my tree and the girl goes um yeah that's
where they live
and I was like no it's no this is where
I live actually thank you I pay you know
yeah and so um uh and it was like it
obviously something's wrong with it it's
sick it's got rabies whatever like and
if it bites something whatever and uh
and then I was like well there's
obviously something wrong with it and
she goes oh well a lot of people after
they test their cocaine for Fentanyl and
if it tests positive they flush it down
the toilet so a lot of raccoons and
coyotes have fentanyl in their blood
system so just
he'll sleep it off oh my God like
fentanyl raccoons that is a bad I'm out
that's a bad I don't like fentanyl
people that's we were we were just in
Burlington last weekend and uh there was
a lot of people on drugs there it's it's
getting rough in Vermont fucking
terrible didn't they just have a flood
did I make that up I don't know if they
had a flood but uh they did not have a
flood of good jokes coming their way
yeah
it's Vermont yeah but they all just like
lost their home so good good fuck them
but uh we had we just walked by this
lady and she just goes fuck you I hope
you suck dicks till you die died and I
was like oh my God what a great fucking
I mean that's the way you want to get
accosted I mean what was she what was
her deal she was just on drugs I don't
know cool I wish I was like out on drugs
that sounds like kind of punk rock I
hope you suck dicks until you die like
when you die of asphyxiation I don't
know it's like a new Stephen King or
just like yeah come toxicity oh yeah I
guess yeah you keep sucking yeah like I
just had Dr Durgan he was talking about
how we project onto people anything we
accuse people of is usually what we're
doing like she's gonna suck dick so she
dies yeah the irony is that's how she'll
I don't know I don't know if she's
meeting a lot of guys oh yeah I don't
think I don't think is her name skipper
dude the redhead name what's her name
redhead Barbie Andrew is my guess not
Midge Midge oh I saw the movie they
mentioned that yeah yeah a midge is a
bug you know what annoying about the
movie too is like the whole message of
like everyone's got a special purpose is
that true I saw a woman in Vermont who
told me to suck dicks till I die I don't
know if everyone's got a purpose we got
a couple minutes out of it on a podcast
thanks bitch thank you Joe call her
Midge purpose was to give you an opener
for the good for you podcast no I just I
don't know it's look it's it's not
people are like it's not for you it's
fine fair enough but they're like it's a
kids movie well then why are they
talking about the patriarchy which child
is like yeah the patriarchy I feel like
you're a movie buff I love movies you
love movies but hold on Oppenheimer I
haven't seen it yet I just when I see
the three hour time like that's a lot of
time I know I love New York because I
saw Michael Shannon walking in the same
theaters he's to me the only hot actor
wow he's the act the only actor to me
that I'm like the only High but Michael
Shannon over Brad Pitt
Brad Pitt is like I'm I get it I'm just
not like Brad Pitt I like a I like a
Sinister dark like
um you know Mall Santa Violet I see how
he got pregnant yeah
no that's uh no I get it he's attractive
yeah I like a like a wonky Vibe no
there's a dark star yeah you're a comic
you appreciate it I like a grittiness I
like I don't like like a I like and I
like someone that doesn't think they're
hot as soon as a guy knows they're hot
in some way I'm like out yeah because he
only he only plays weirdos dude him in
shape of water is just impeccable his
performance is impact he's also so
talented yeah
nocturnal animals he was awesome oh dude
he's like he'll go there I'm like this
guy knows how to fuck like this guy does
weird shit like weird do you think
Michael Shannon ever thought he Whitney
Cummins would be talking about how he
knows how to fuck on a podcast dude
Michael Shannon podcasts are amazing
dude Michael Shannon will fish hook a
bitch wow in the backseat of the
maneuver like I just know like he's like
gets down or he's like been married for
12 years and has four can you imagine
driving an Uber and Michael Shannon's
fingering a girl on your back stick
you're like is that the dude from
fucking yeah
yeah I guess you could Fish Hook
someone's that's yeah you could do that
too I guess I was so dumb that when I
was a kid my Grandpa took me fishing off
like a thing and I I didn't know what I
only saw in movies so they always throw
it back so I just threw it back and then
when I pulled it just went right into my
leg
I fucking fish hooked myself yeah
there's lots of uh uh my aunt when I
lived in Virginia worked at Orvis which
is a big fishing outlet place and we'd
go fishing and fly fishing which is like
the one where you kind of like tease it
in people's like the coolest one people
would just like walk by with hooks in
their face like it would just be like
they were just gone it was just like
half the people fucking awful half the
people that did it like I gotta get a
head out I hooked my eyeball again I
mean it was like in their eyelids it was
just like a nightmare yeah it's hard to
do if the wind hits the wrong way you
got it
um Oppenheimer is good though it's worth
seeing uh yeah I'm gonna try to see it I
want to talk about some movie drama
because you're a movie guy because I'm
kind of feel like like here's the thing
that bothers me about movies these days
I feel like I'm watching movies being
sports like everyone's just gunning for
an Oscar it feels like I hate that shit
and I feel like I'm watching sports I
know everyone's like I gotta do the
craziest thing to win an Oscar I gotta
play Oppenheimer I gotta age myself I
gotta do this like it just feels like
you guys are all trying to win a trophy
instead of make movies for us not that
they're bad yeah like to me that's what
this Bradley Cooper thing is is he's
just like I gotta to win an Oscar you
gotta use a prosthetic you got to do
like it just looks like an Oscar play
but everyone else's thing is they're
like he put on a prosthetic nose and
that's Jew face yeah I didn't I didn't
appreciate the horns but I thought the
noise was fine
let me see his dick I do see if he's
circumcised for the movie right that
would be impressive no he uh even the
Anti-Defamation League was like this is
fine which they were the one first ones
who are like you know complaining so
it's also more just cringe because it's
like what you don't have to do this
first of all no one knows what this guy
looks like he's playing a famous
composer which that's a whole other
thing for me like I don't want to watch
music
no but this could be good I liked um
the drumming one Whiplash that was
fucking awesome that I loved yeah I need
to watch someone compose it could be
he's got an interesting life I mean he's
like a womanizing maestro he's gay oh
he's gay which that to me is the weird
thing that he's like gay men need big
noses shit like maybe he was like he's
gay yeah the composer is gay so that's
the whole story so they're like gay guys
need big noses to get done what they do
I've never heard I've never heard the
term jewface before except as a slur I
feel so it's just funny that like he's
doing jewface I'm like I've literally oh
that's more offensive than what he's
doing that word uh but no I don't uh no
I don't think anyone I think it's also
who's making the movie like if Mel
Gibson is producing the movie this is a
bad choice but if it's like if it's
anyone else you're kind of like oh yeah
they were probably trying to make him
look different because because as an
actor you do get the point you're like
oh I'm just watching Bradley Cooper in
this movie I'm watching Bradley Cooper
in this movie yeah he's great I love
Bradley it's also like
for a movie I want to know they were in
the makeup chair for four and a half
hours trying to dazzle me and entertain
me that's why apparently Orson Welles
you should always say like actors are
the dumbest people you ever meet because
back in the day they would just sit in a
makeup chair for like five hours shoot
their lines and then try to fuck someone
she was like they don't read They're not
smart people and by the way back then
the makeup was so toxic like I'm
obsessed with the like behind the scenes
stories of like Wizard of Oz and Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory the number of
people that died of cancer from um
Wizard of Oz because of how toxic all
the green paint was the woman got all
these like burns on her face the Tin Man
like caught on fire because they used
just like aluminum and Mercury like not
bad enough you're like one of the little
people in Wizard of Oz now your face
caves in dude it's awful a lot of them
uh one of them committed suicide on the
production and they were um and they
raped or molesting her the whole time oh
my God damn
um I think women have it bad in
Hollywood now the lead actress is
getting raped by dwarves back then now I
mean uh no it's also like in movies all
the time I mean Gary Oldman put on a fat
suit to play Churchill no one's like
that's fattest I'm sorry have you seen
Rosie O'Donnell's riding the bus with my
sister that looks fucking rough that's
for that to me is like that's one where
I'm like that should not have been made
but also thank God it was I thought it
was me dude I hit that trailer a couple
times a week but like that's if I'm
giving you 18 I better see a big swing
yeah I want to see a big swing okay so
are you ready
podcast
do you know what I just said
how do you like my podcast
but in German
I've been getting very into learning
speaking German I'm not I'm not like I I
I'm still trying to get Spanish down
okay but I took a break because I can't
stop reading these books about Hitler
I don't know how this something happens
and there's a certain point in your life
I don't see them having kids I don't
know what's going on I'm just in a
Hitler
because I'm pregnant I don't know all of
a sudden I'm into sex toys and Hitler
it's very this is very odd but I'm
trying to learn Spanish uh because I
want my kid to learn Spanish like from
the gecko it's also not that hard I
gotta be honest with Babel you can start
speaking a new language in just three
weeks I am so sick of speaking just
English it's so boring I'm just like I'm
sick of being an annoying American who's
like hey y'all like I'm about to have a
kid I'm determined for him to not be an
idiot like me and only know one language
one of my best friends already promised
to teach him Spanish and I don't want
them to have like a secret language
where they collude against me it's good
for the hinge bio to say you know all of
those languages because now on dating
apps everyone's you know everyone's in
France now I don't know everyone left
America at least all the founders those
are the guys that I match with on him
anyway there's a special limited time
deal for our listeners to get started
right now you're gonna get 55 off that's
wild your Babel subscription but only
for our listeners at babel.com good for
you get 55 off at babel.com good for you
spell Babel
b-a-b-b-e-l.com good for you all one
word I'm proud of you for learning a new
language girl I mean the Bradley Cooper
thing I just I have so many thoughts on
this because I I think to me the oddest
thing is the fact that
his nose is already pretty big it is
pretty big it's not like the fact that
he was like guys we need him I need a
big nose for this and everyone's like no
no one wanted
yeah yeah I guess we need to add
Prosthetics like I just like when actors
get more and more dysmorphic throughout
their career and their choice he's like
I gotta put on a prosthetic nose so it
looks like I have a big nose and
everyone's like okay cool you didn't
have to do that he's got a good big nose
but it's big it's I don't
I don't know I think there's like the to
even respond to the outrage seems a
little bit ridiculous but I like that
comedians aren't the only ones getting
attacked for dumb shit I feel like now
these guys get a tag more because I
think it's clear comedians don't give a
shit yeah it's like these guys oh
communities are like what do you want
it's a joke what was these he this is
not a joke this is the dramatic play
yeah so he's more vulnerable to
criticism you know we're like uh but
apparently Bernstein's family is happy
with it they're fine so it's like who
gives he just wanted to wear it yeah
you're right it's an Oscar play he's
trying to get an Oscar yep dude no one
watches Oscar movies anymore if you are
going to take three hours of my time and
my money I want I want Jake Gyllenhaal
and Heath Ledger I want you to convince
me you're gay I want to watch you to
ruin your friendship yeah I want you two
to never be able to make eye contact
again I heard Mark Wahlberg turned down
the gyllenhole goal what that would have
been such a good do you ever see that
episode of extras where Ricky Gervais
won't like he brings all his high school
friends he's in a gay play by Ian
McKellen and he has a kiss and he won't
do it because his high school friends
that's that's Wahlberg also why not
think about okay so why is it that if
you put on a fake nose it's Jew face but
if you get a nose job off camera that's
not anti-semitic I was offended by
Jennifer Gray Jennifer Gray
you know no I I mean who get I mean who
gives a shit though it's like is that
where we've gotten as a society like
look at his nose like get you need to do
something with your time but I don't
think anyone was actually really
offended I think like once the
Anti-Defamation League is like it's
nothing then then no one really has I
saw the Jerusalem Post was like we're
good here guys like the hall monitor
dorks on Twitter like is this uh no
we're good okay yeah he's good and it's
like as you said he's like a clearly got
a good rep is like a do you remember the
concept of citizens arrest yeah
that's Twitter now
it's that would be citizens arrest
people the idiots are you doing drugs
I'm taking citizens arrest like those
people are just like on Twitter now yeah
being dorks it was that John Ronson book
so you've been publicly shamed remember
that one so that was an incredible book
because he's like that should be you
should have to prove you've read that to
get on Twitter just so you know the harm
that can be gone because yeah I think
I think it's going away a little bit
Yeah because there's fatigue and also
like the shit you see people losing it
over it's like they just move they went
from Jonah Hill to lizzo there's no
right right there's no intention the add
is getting better or worse so they just
jump to the next it's just whack-a-mole
at this point like but I think the
people have always used celebrities as
punching bags or famous people's
punching bags we just never saw before
because how could we and it's also when
people are sanctimonious like I think
Jonah Hill made a movie about how like
enlightened he is that doesn't matter
about there and then so then you do that
and lizzo is like I'm so body positive
and then you treat people you work we
don't like Hypocrites exactly so I think
that's what but then also how long are
you gonna really punish someone I think
it's really more like I'm very grateful
that that's as someone that is like
identified with having a lot of
addictions I'm glad that's not like
needing someone to fail or something
like I don't like it when someone you're
a self-loathing train wreck no one will
ever come for you you're safe
you're self-deprecating and that I think
I think it feels a little arrogant to be
like like I I couldn't finish that Jonah
Hill Doc and and I like Jonah Hill I'm a
fan of his but I just I don't want to
watch
about like I this is a great therapist
but then it kind of becomes about you
and how this guy's helped you and you're
kind of like say self-indulgent feels
like the subtext is like I'm doing great
now and I and I
I just don't seem to over compensate or
something when someone advertises how
well they're doing and I think for
Comics that's so anathema to us because
our thing is like we advertise our
shadow what she talks about that that
that documentary like we go I'm a piece
of shit I make all these mistakes I'm
gonna you know but we don't have secrets
in private whereas I think most people
they're like everyone's great secrets
but I think when you when you play it up
like I'm a fucking I'm an enlightened
per it's the whole reason we hate
politicians who are like I'm this uh you
know the guy who hates the gays is
sucking cock behind us or something you
know it's like being sanctimonious it's
always like what are you hiding like if
someone's like you know are you a good
person to be like I try to be like those
are the people you want to trust not the
people that are like oh I'm the best and
I'm like moving those are the people
they're gonna get it next or like that
guy's a work in progress I don't know if
he is I don't think he's really working
on himself they're gonna get more
descriptive with how they go after you
yeah it just feels a little bit uh yeah
people that want to advertise how great
of a person they are it's like Cosby 101
it's like Cosby's like the good guy that
was telling other people do something
he has an app he has an app now he has a
legit app I'm down yeah
it's just White Noise it just puts you
to sleep
he is fucking here's a good segue
speaking of sleep last night
comedian much last night at like 10
o'clock you texted me I'm watching the
documentary about the Long Island killer
and you watched the better one than I
watched it till two in the morning I was
watching I was watching the Gilgo Beach
guy but I was it was on Hulu I was just
flipping on Hulu and it's the Harvey
Levin TMZ one which I'm like oh so now
these guys are like trying to take
themselves seriously as like fucking
journalists well no because the victims
were hot they're like we'll do this one
yeah they were they were like they look
like stuff and he and the Killer looks
like fat Dead behind the ice Tucker
Carlson dude 100 dude he's also very
tall he's he's like six four this killer
I didn't know his voice until I watched
it he sounds like pure Long Island trash
I was expecting something more you
always picture these villains to be more
sophisticated from like all the movies
we watch and stuff no my favorite part
about it is that so this guy killed like
eight to ten women or something who
knows maybe more in this room and they
said like maybe a kid there was like and
they're like and their toddler was found
and you're like what the fuck and like
any guy he's like that kid ain't mine
you know just the women you know but uh
no he it was a midget it was a midget
stripper it was a girl she was hot
um it was wild because he was a boomer
serial killer like he was even shocked
that he had been caught he was Googling
why hasn't the Long Island
that was one of his main Google searches
it's like why can't they find this they
were like insecure like entertainers but
they Google themselves so like no one's
talking about me and also no one was
talking about him to the point to where
he would call the families from the
phone
I mean the there was one I don't know if
they did this in the one and then they
were like we don't really care like he
wasn't getting like the high he wanted
from killing them he's like six five too
and and an oaf and uh he was uh you ever
see a movie Man Hunter from the 80s no
man dude it's a giant murderer who
watches one it's a great movie it's
actually crazy because sometimes when I
think murder I go oh Napoleon complex
like short guy that needs to and you're
like this guy's a 6'4 that's just like
you're built in a lab to be a serial
killer and you're like I guess I gotta
go play basketball you don't have to be
he's like I couldn't play basketball I'm
just gonna choke a bitch that looks like
a cheerleader like you're just like
um
I don't know like I don't know usually
it's some squirrely ass little dude
that's not how you pick it's almost two
on the nose right it's almost like hack
to be a serial killer when you're that
but he also was just like it is he was
yeah
he's a fucking man like that's how I did
it how did Sam know finally he was so uh
it's funny they were like saying he was
like actually like a Charming guy no one
would have saw it coming and then you
see how he behaves you're not it's like
when they said Bundy's Charming I'm like
have you never met another person this
guy's a fucking lunatic exactly it these
guys are sorry they're like it seems
like a really good guy and like no
wonder how you were dead that guy does
not he's comes up so creepy such a
bummer that's to me the part that like
it's the most for some reason it's so
much more fucked up to kill call girls
and just like I know because I'm like
it's just such a vulnerable
professional yeah I mean and it's like
this fucking they're like he's so
Charming we couldn't get a date he was
creeping out call girls he told me he's
married with a kid yeah he also had a
wife so what's what's up with the cereal
colors that have the wife do you think
that they stay with the wife because
they know that'll be like a good cover
Imagining the wife of a guy who and you
find out he's killed 10 women and he's
just like in your house every day oh my
God I get shit for leaving the seat up
are you kidding me I can't imagine no
it's uh I can't imagine I mean that's
got to be a rough con conversation
but it's like do they still say we need
to talk yeah is it the same I don't know
uh it's why because you know Ted Bundy
had a Jenna Friedman really brilliant
comedian had this um has this YouTube
series it's called uh whatever the
girl's name something in Ted and it's
like based on um she got I think the
season assist from The New York Times
because she was spoofing those New York
Times Like wedding things I remember
that that was maybe when they were like
black and white like going through the
city like talking about their marriage
and it was about
um Ted Bundy's girlfriend who he lived
with when he would just come home like
covered in blood and she would like just
like be living with a serial killer like
that would be a good sitcom like a three
camera like we just play it like laugh
track style yeah it's just so it
literally that's what she was kind of
leaning into it's like serial killers
really like to have uh like a steady
girl that's what keeps them hating women
or something he's like I'm not gonna be
able to keep my rage up for women if I'm
not married yeah if you're single you'll
be like no fuck it'll stop actually
you know like is being married what
makes him need to murder these women or
do you just get married I'd be a great
defense like look at her she's fucking
awful this is why
I didn't kill her but I had to kill
someone
so y'all I'm pregnant and there's a lot
of things people don't tell you about
pregnancy people do tell you their
secrets people do come up to you and
they're just like hey I drank my whole
pregnancy and like honestly the kid
turned out fine he's a little short but
the helmet makes up for the difference
like they will just admit they'll tell
you I tore six and a half inches and
like they tell you everything except how
horny you are when you're pregnant
that's the one thing nobody told me I've
heard some theories about it
one is how you get really horny so that
the father or some man bonds emotionally
to you so you have protection over the
baby although do you want the man that
was obsessed with having sex with a
pregnant girl to be the protector of
your child I don't know but like it was
wild in tribal times okay I guess it
makes sense that you'd want to get some
guy attached to you to help you defend
the baby from Lions since they used to
come out just covered and I guess they
still come out covered in blood but
there's less I don't know hopefully
there's no lions at Cedar cyanide where
I'm giving birth
um but so there's that so there's like
apparently a biological basis for this
you know also I guess being horny it
helps you give birth sex induces labor I
was reading about I wonder if sex toys
do because if so
I'm gonna have this baby any minute
okay
I am so late to the game on sex toys I
am so bad at myself for dabbling in
antidepressants and weed and all kinds
of things when sex toys were right there
the whole time okay I just for longest I
don't know they're the ultimate life
hack okay you're no more you have you
have to worry is the sex gonna be good
he doesn't have to worry if she's
getting satisfied it's on you to satisfy
yourself it's 20 23 people okay tell
them what you need bring the toy show
them okay they'll love it it's like a
video game controller where the highest
level is you squirting
okay I have I have a whole situation now
I've gone hard on the sex toys I have
one by my bed I got a little charging
station this is the ultimate form of
self-care I'm telling you stop I don't
take sleeping pills anymore okay just
get one of my toys from fun love doze
off to sleep and not one text to a weird
ex and a fit of horniness I handle it
all these people talk about depression
and try just try a toy from fun love
anxiety try a toy from fun love tell me
if you're still depressed and anxious
honestly every crazy person I see having
a meltdown on Twitter I'm like
you guys need to go to funlove.com
there's something to satisfy any desire
at funlove.com so what are you waiting
for explore discover indulge and make
love Fun by visiting fun love.com for a
limited time my listeners can save 25
off your first order by entering the
code Whitney at checkout go to fun
f-u-n-l-o-v-e.com and use code Whitney
at checkout to save 25 today that's fun
love.com and code Whitney to save and
make fun love today
who is like a hero who you met who was
awesome uh
oh gosh a lot I feel like most people
kind of are
um Paul Riser yeah so cool like I I like
really Paul rise was like for whatever
reason really big deal for me like I
read his book couple Hood when I was
like 12 I found like a flea market I was
like this is how I think like I focus on
the weird shit like this you know
um and then he's just like the coolest
the calm it's like he knows people freak
out on him and he knows what to do to
make you be like no I'm just a person
like he just knew exactly what to do
um like Margaret Atwood who wrote The
handmaid's Tale like she yeah she just
like handled it and was like not
Margaret Atwood after like a couple
minutes that's cool have you a Blake
Griffin like there's a lot of people
that are like yeah I forgot your huge
your Hoops fan yeah yeah like he was
like well we work together on something
and it's like when you're just a fan of
someone's work and then they just make
themselves a human being like they just
know what to do I met I love Jalen
Bronson from the Knicks and I met him at
a game uh uh early in the year and I
sucked I blew I totally blew it I just
uh
I was at a Rangers game I was with uh I
was with garyvee or Liz who's the
manager at the comedy Center I'm sure
you met yeah and then uh and Rachel
Feinstein were at the game and uh and
the Knicks PR guys like Jalen brunson's
coming in just so you know he's coming
to the game and I'm like fucking jam
with Bronson he's like you should say
what's up like they know I'm I'm bugging
out he's my favorite player so uh I'm
usually cool in these scenarios but I
just sucked I fucking uh I was like
thank you so much for coming to the
Knicks and he was like oh and then Liz
had to jump in like he's a comedian with
a Netflix special he's not just a psycho
and uh and that helped a little I was
like man I fuck it he was so nice you
could he is what you expect he's gonna
but there's also people we're friends
with that I used to be fans of like I
mean like Louis CK and Colin Quinn and
like Adele like where you're like I
legitimately forgot how I used to would
like freak out if I was sitting next to
you you know tell uh yeah he's I mean
they're all great guys yeah New York
comedy's so fucking cool I mean like
though I miss seeing a tell I've been
calling in late because I have this damn
drilling on my apartment for like a year
New York's insane but I don't I I look I
love New York I would love to be the
type of person that can live there
without being you could handle New York
I love it I think for me it's more about
the what you get for your money drives
me a little nuts like I'm kind of like
uh really you know as most people I
would imagine are just like sort of like
for what I'm paying for this this is
just not a pro or like this is a bad
deal I don't like getting screwed I was
like paying like a crazy amount of money
for this like one better room the
plumbing never worked like there was an
elevator that people would get off while
I was sleeping and like the hearing
people screaming I'm like 2 A.M a woman
screaming like do I help do I go outside
is this am I an accomplice like I just
don't need that shit right now well no
you know what New York is it's like a
chick who is hot in like the 70s and
then just got like really fat and and
crazy and you're like you're you've got
to be nicer now and she's gotten worse
somehow no it's I think you forget she
dances like this at the wedding
like she's just like
like too much wine like rose all day
she's like I'm getting better with age
like this wine you're like you're not
actually that is the fucking attitude
though where you're there and you're
just like how do people I don't know how
people handle it it's Stockholm syndrome
yeah I mean if there's a little bit of
that I do like a little abuse probably
but to me like I went to New York to
write my book and it worked like the
energy the like I'm in New York and I
need to write and you would go out to
like get a coffee and everyone would be
like in a rush and be like look at us
we're like look how important we all are
like I totally like it I'm into that
sexiness of like the one day a year the
weather's good you're like look at that
like it just kind of you it really is
like two weeks truly and then everyone's
outside like eating gelato like you know
and um I I like the not taking something
for granted and things are always kind
of hard so when you do get like a little
nibble it's like being a toxic
relationship it's like a gambling
addiction ultimately yeah we're all
Rihanna with Chris Brown yeah and when
he saw Smiles at us once a year but he's
an amazing dancer what a great guy he's
an amazing dancer at the end you're
right there's something so sexy about it
and uh but at the end of the day when
you're like writing that check and
you're like because there's a couple
things as I you know that I won't budge
on baths
I gotta be able to have a bath and this
plumber came if you
flush the toilet I want to say say if
the effluvium would come through the
bath like the just it would just be like
dwarf smell nice and I called a plumber
and I was like oh every time I flush
this toilet it'll smell like not from me
pooping or anything it just smell like
sewage would come out of the dream and
he was like New York Plumbing
and I'm like that's it he's like yes 120
year old plumbing and you're like so
there's no solution he's like not really
like that's just it that sounds like a
bad plumber there's someone should be
able to fix it
this dude I I had a plumber come by the
other day and there
sometimes you just go with what the
buildings like we use these people we
use them and they have like a weird
relationship maybe that yeah yeah so I
use this company I looked them up on
Google I shit you not it's 30 straight
one star reviews I'm like I've never
seen this batter rating for that feels
like an ex-girlfriend pissed off no but
it's like they're all like everyone was
like they're the worst plumber but the
plumbing in the city is awful you know
what I mean like how do you fix 20 year
old 120 year old Plumbing yeah true but
they came by they did suck they I mean
they ended up fixing it but the first
day they got they did a consultation
quickly but then they just didn't show
up the first day wild and I was like you
can get away with fucking murder in New
York in many ways but like that's kind
of beach that yeah for 15. Long Island
and then it was like to get everything
was I think my deal is that the hard
things can be hard but the easy things
shouldn't be hard and sometimes in New
York the easy things are hard really I
just got to pick up this and then I
gotta get groceries and you're like I
can only get so many groceries because I
have to carry these home and now my
fingers fingers the grocery store
delivers now I like getting my own
groceries this is like getting clams
delivered there's certain things that I
want to get that's what the go go Beach
killer did they got clams delivered
Craigslist
I can't get off this one
no but you really can
you really can get anything delivered
there I understand you want to go then
you're waiting for like I don't spend my
whole 20s waiting for men to show up I'm
not I just spent my whole child this is
a different issue that's not that's not
you can't bring it waiting on the
bicycle guy that has my Pokeball
and then there's a new thing we're doing
groceries not the Poke people spending
five dollars to cap someone bring me
well I'm not Marie Antoinette I'm
already spending fucking she did not
have this option to get this much food
delivered four thousand dollars to live
in like a you know like cheese wheel so
it's like I'm not gonna I don't because
then you're like where's the guy and
where's the bike guy is that him and
then you're like dealing I'll give you
this some days it's I I'm I I love it
and I I can't leave and it's like a part
of me but there's some days I go out and
I'm like I cannot believe that they get
away with this shit it's wild it is
amazing I mean just like just a dude
just in your face there was a Drilling
in my home so I have to leave a lot of
days like it's so fucking loud it's
literally outside my window so I had to
leave and the second I go out a guy just
starts screaming cursing in my face like
a guy who's on fucking fentanyl or
somebody's like fuck you what the fuck
are you looking at started you ever
seemed like the common denominator the
people that yell at you yeah
it's just like uh
no but he gets in my face and I'm like
that so I can't be home I can't be in
the street can't and then you did it to
a lot of people he did it to a woman
with a dog he's like fuck you and fuck
your dog he was a crazy guy but uh did
you ever discover any subscriptions you
forgot about or paid twice and didn't
realize it until you already gave 700 to
the Jenna Jameson Fleshlight
subscription Club ever find out that you
got stoned five years ago and you did
some Auto subscription giving seven
dollars a month to save pandas
pandas
you know you know that old save the
pandas racket you fell for one night
when you were feeling weak well that
fake panda charity was a scam let's be
honest and you're still dropping 400
bones a month to say fake pandas been
there Auto subscriptions you forgot
about robbing you blind story of my life
I realized a month ago I still belong to
like three gyms in Philadelphia
drives me nuts you log into PornHub one
time to get a digital girlfriend and
they're just charging you for years this
is how they get you some company what
they do is they say four months free
just put in your credit card and you'll
have four months free and they Bank on
you forgetting
you know what I mean I don't want to
have to go in and undo the whole thing I
just want to ghost this subscription
it's like they're they're on you it's
like dating someone for four months you
just want to never talk to them again
but they think you're still together
that's what they're like well you never
officially broke up with me but you knew
you knew you guys track everything we do
you know I haven't been on this website
for you know I just wanted one article
ah well fret no more rocket money is
here to save the day rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place stop
wasting money on things you don't use
cancel your unwanted subscriptions and
manage your money the easy way by going
to rocketmoney.com Whitney that's
rocketmoney.com Whitney rocketmoney.com
Whitney
what's the song I have Mom brain it
ain't nothing to cut that bitch off
[Laughter]
that's my new motto there's something
very fucked up in egalitarian about New
York but like even Mayor Bloomberg would
ride the subway and like shortly like
that sure was a PR stunt but it's also
like it is the best way to get around
yeah so like there's something cool
about everyone being on the same like in
L.A you're just in your car for fucking
you know every there's something so
isolated about that right no you listen
to podcasts you talk on the phone I
would never talk on the phone if I was
didn't get in the car I'd talk on the
phone yeah I I don't you know it makes
me it forces me to yeah that's the other
thing about New Yorkers I'm glad you
said it you guys lack some very basic
skills as people that look could survive
a zombie apocalypse I can't I'd never
claim to I'd be the first dead no
question I'd be doing this shit and
they'd kill me but why not drive I have
a license but if I if you were in a car
with me you'd be like I wouldn't I would
never want to drive someone's car who's
nice to me
because I will ruin it I'll ruin you
I'll break your car so but like New
Yorkers lack I feel like a lot of very
basic
learn how to drive but there's something
polite about having no manners there's
something very honest about having no
Mana sure sure Fair it's being direct
sure fair I do feel like New York has
chilled out a little bit though it feels
like it's not the mob scene that it was
for a while like after the pandemic I
went back and I was like walking around
and it was like kind of like chill and I
was like I like it here but I shouldn't
some cities got worse I remember we were
walking around Salt Lake City downtown
and it's like a fucking video game you
feel like you're playing GTA yeah only
if you get killed you're fucking dead
like people at one point people just run
after us I was with Gary we just were
like we're like we're just jogging we
we're just jogging in like jeans like
homeless people which is not a good look
when you're jogging in shorts It's a
good look in jeans it's a fucking
problem you know something bad has
happened yeah
um what was going on there just people
on drugs crazy we were just we were
cracking up while we were right that's
just everywhere now huh every downtown
got worse after covet and Drugs in this
country are fucking horrible I mean it's
like everyone talks about it but then
you don't you just don't it's an
afterthought you don't think about it
until you actually it's in front of you
and you're like this person is suffering
yeah I feel really bad and you have to
be so that's why they're so aggressive
is like to survive on the street you
have to be like all bark yeah yeah I
mean I was the across the street from
the Improv A friend of mine has a hair
salon and it's also a different kind of
whatever this drug is that homeless
people are on now I don't know what
remix it is like you normally like I
grew up in DC at a time where it was
like you know it was wild like our mayor
did crack and everyone you know and uh
and you can walk towards a homeless
person sometimes and just use your butt
you can use your body to move someone
you know what I mean like if you're
walking through the airport it's like a
thing it's with like if you're an animal
person it's like if you look at the
person's opposite shoulder you can
normally just move them out of your way
with your energy you know
um
so this homeless person opens the
unhoused do I have to say that
um it comes in and they're like rip now
dude like they're like cut up like he
was in like shorts did every fucking
hobo get the bread and hit Fight Club V
it's insane right I was like what the
hell I'm working hard in the gym and I
look like shit and these fucking guys
look incredible like a machinist charges
in dude and he looks right at me and I
kind of because my friend's you know
scared she works there whatever and I'm
good with that I'm like fight there's
some fight fight and freeze I'm always
fight because if you're just calm like
it's gonna usually de-escalate the
situation so I got up and I was like hey
bud like let's go for a walk like walk
towards him and instead of him just
instinctively kind of flinching as
anyone would having someone move quickly
towards you while making eye contact he
moved towards me and so I went in to
move him and he just like went right
into me like his eyes I was like this is
a different drug this is like yeah
fentanyl meth Adderall they don't feel
fear there's no it used to be homeless
people just kind of Street sleeping
passed out you step over them now
they're like doing cold plunges and you
know I don't know like they're strong
and they're powerful
yeah there's something it is weird that
it does have like an apocalypse zombie
movie type Vibe like we were in downtown
Portland Oregon we're like this is like
fucking the last of us or something this
is a friend of mine truly last night
lives in Portland and he's like I've got
to get out of there it's like it's crazy
well didn't they have they have their
own City they basically formed their own
City with no law enforcement over there
I think they also
decriminalized drugs it was something
where like they're not uh they have like
methadone clinics and that's like the
weird phrasing where it's like not
technically like legal but it's you
don't get arrested for it or something I
don't know dude they need a reboot
Portlandia now I know just a different
vibe like man Fred is a fucking spear
he's just stabbing people so in addition
to being incredibly horny the other
thing about pregnancy is that you're
just always at the doctor it's a real
rigmarole you go to one doctor and
they're like you need to go an
endocrinologist and then he's like you
need to go to a rheumatologist so
basically you're giving me five jury
duties by the time you call the one
specialist you wait for the call back
you go to the waiting room you're
waiting naked wearing a napkin it's cold
it's four it's four days of your life
door to door I'm like I'll be dead by
that like I'm whatever thing I have it's
way worse I think that's why they call
you a patient because you have to be
very patient to get through this whole
process why does it take so long for
people at the front desk just to answer
the phone look you knew this was the job
what do you like what do you say you do
for a living someone's like what do you
do I try to not answer phones at the
doctor's office
they should be prescribing Adderall to
the women at the front desk not the
patience I can't get into any doctor's
appointments but thanks to ZocDoc now I
can okay ZocDoc they have more doctors
than Jay day
ZocDoc is a free app where you can find
amazing doctors and book appointments
online we're talking about booking
appointments with thousands of top-rated
patient reviewed doctors and Specialists
you can filter specifically for the ones
who take your insurance are located near
you and treat almost any condition
you're searching for
I am obsessed with ZocDoc I use it and
so should you that's docdoc.com Whitney
zocdoc.com slash Whitney maybe you'll
find a husband or wife I have a special
coming out in November I would rather do
like 10 podcasts of cool people than
like a Fallon or a you know whatever
because you're gonna anyone listening to
those podcasts are already gonna be cool
you know what I mean I'm not having
people I'm not promoting the special
with a bunch of people here Isn't that
cool to just do like back in the day you
just do one late night and you're like
I'm done how was that that was it now
it's eight minutes but this is this has
been a fun podcast but I do feel like
you do some podcasts where you're like
just it's like a date where you just
don't Vibe with the person dude it used
to be you could just do Leno Letterman
you're in you're out eight minutes now I
have to drive to like five guys at
garages they have to like prank call my
mom I have to like talk about being
molested I have to hear about their
depression it's it is I know I'm you
know I'm sick of it fucking every
comedian being having anxiety dude
you're a performer you perform in front
of stopping a comic if this is so
stressful for you it is everyone 's
number one fear but uh
it's interesting I think the way we were
just talking though about like the
peeves and stuff I feel like people
should do that that should be like a
first date that's how people should go
because what are people talking about
like their interests like like I like
this movie movie Fine Music fine but
like what bothers you what bothers you
on the why don't you ever do that in the
first day that's how you should all no
one does it let's just there was a
dating app that was just dislikes for a
while I always Oh I thought you were
coming up with something that's a real
thing I think it was because I came up
with it and then I found out it was real
it's called hater what see that's
fucking up launching February 8th I
don't know what year that was
um and it was just going like I hate
this I hate this I hate this
I think maybe people it maybe didn't
catch on because like negativity but I
think like there should be a thing like
deal breakers yeah totally totally like
bottom lines things I can't stand
because I feel like you waste so much
time when you're hanging out with
someone like trying to go like look how
fun I am and I like know I love hiking
like I'm canoeing my favorite yes but
totally sunsets it's like not dude just
by the way who hates Sunset is someone
like okay I don't I don't like sunsets
dude they really fucking piss me off
someone that gets migraines oh God
you're one of those
Jesus easy Mother can I call you mom for
the rest of this my mom would just be in
the room like I can't I can't be around
anyone I've got a migraine I know when
you're driving like against the Sun at
like 6 15 or whatever when that
is their son or your son because I feel
like I'm talking to my mom right now
and also like dude are you like ice
packed on the head laying down just like
gel oh my God not anymore since I've
gone off birth control I haven't had
migraines as much that was actually like
triggering it
um so we'll just have to keep getting
you pregnant every every like year and a
half stay a handmade yeah but like I do
feel like sunsets pissed me off because
when you see them you're like that's the
most beautiful thing I've ever seen and
you try to take a picture of it and it's
never as good and then you like post it
and you're like what am I doing I'm like
so don't still keep Instagram out of it
just you know that's for you you know
what other people post sunsets you're
like really yeah it's just like
it's too beautiful of a thing it like it
bothers me wow that's a fucking weird
and by the way you just like the
migraine thing is hilarious that you're
a migraine person because that's like
that's like my childhood is my mom just
like my head oh no no
you're really annoyed you know my mom
did to me the other day I got I had like
a horrible flight situation where are
you guys like homies yeah I'm close to
my mom but like we but she also is like
there's that classic like
I call it like fucking Jiu Jitsu where
it's like you just you have to like come
you like complaining energies well I
imagine like Jews you into a corner it's
like Jewish Tai Chi where like she takes
my complaint and then wraps it so you
think that's bad I'm like all right you
win but I was complaining about a flight
being delayed I'm like fucking she's
like the airlines are struggling I'm
like
tiny with United you're my mom what the
fuck is wrong with you
I hate that shit and I had the airlines
are having a hard day they keep getting
bailed out they're not having a hard
time I'm having a hard time Mom you're
gonna be fired up you know I do this
sometimes and I hate it when I do it I
hate it when people do it to me and then
I find myself doing it it's like I'm
trying to make someone feel better
but they just want to feel the anger and
you know you got to let them feel the
end yeah it's like when someone's like
uh my Instagram comments someone just
called me a whore and I'm like well
people are in a lot of pain I mean
imagine how much pain you have to be in
to write a negative comment about
someone and it's like why did I do that
why didn't I just I know that sucks I
just got raped by a homeless person well
you were his only option yeah he's
homeless adversity is actually good like
you'll get a great bit out of it like I
have you'll get a great bit it's the
best one
by the way that's the first thing I said
to you when I saw you pregnant right I
was like I was like you're gonna get a
great joke yeah why do you think I did
it I saw the bump and I was like this is
gonna be
how much your new hour is uh gonna be
almost zero oh great yeah the new hour
is like I have a couple jokes about it
um but like for me like I have a really
hard time not doing like a couple things
on one thing like I because I hate
Segways so much like they are so
embarrassing to me that I tend to do
specials that are like one big theme so
you can just go from thing to thing so I
feel like the next one will be just that
you know because I get frustrated when I
can't I remember I heard Gary Waldman
once say
I just love Gary and I love his work
um he said like with each premise you
have to and I just remember it changing
the way that I think about comedy was a
gift to milk it for like everything it's
worth so for me like just a couple jokes
about it I like makes me annoyed yeah I
mean he's amazing at that he he gets
every joke I mean it's like he'll have
like a 12 minute bit you know on mangoes
yeah you're like how did you like huh he
smokes the mango to death yeah he's just
from every oh yeah I remember he I saw
the um I don't know if the bachelor
about it he's like mangoes have such a
low yield they're such a I mean only he
would say that low the best word choice
for a fucking fruit chunk he's like yeah
no he's uh yeah he's a great comic he he
got me into the comedy seller he was my
wreck at the comedy seller back in the
day love love Gary I do think a lot like
my last couple specials I've tried to do
like like my fourth one I did one topic
robots pretty much the whole special and
then that's when I had maybe two topics
total so robot was crazy crazy that was
fucking crazy
I mean but like I look back and I'm like
was that batshit crazy like it was fun
crazy at the time it was just like
why not it's I have migraines from
sunsets crazy it's not you know it's fun
crazy it's I hate The Beatles crazy
it was it was funny I like it it was and
also it had happened at a time where
that that
um special in the net had come out
where people were sort of like really
torn on it like is it comedy is it not
but it was like seemed like it was
really popular and what ended up
happening is I guess at the end she
talks about getting sexually assaulted
yeah she am I misidentifying and
probably
um and uh people would say oh did you
see the ad did you see the end and
people go no I haven't seen it was like
The Crying Game you had to stick around
for the last some people go literally
and people go back and watch it and then
I heard from someone at Netflix we can
get people to start specials we can't
get them to finish them which I still
think in hours a long time you know I
agree you know the one that I'm doing uh
my next special I might do it as like a
half hour I feel like podcasts people
want to hear they're always like that
was too short but with specials I feel
like they're so dense like this I feel
like people can throw in the background
but stand up requires all of your
attention so I think they the special
has to be like 50 minutes yeah and then
but the reason there are six to have to
be over 60 for like Netflix and stuff is
in order to qualify for an Emmy it has
to be over 60 minutes yeah so there's
that's not something I'm really worried
about I mean it's like whatever like are
we trying to get it's like what we said
at the beginning about this thing are we
all just trying to get trophies are we
trying to make people laugh you know
it's like I'm trying to get another
fucking weird like thing to have on you
know but um uh so I was like hearing
that I was like okay like and I try to
be
smart about that you know I try to not
just be like people were to watch it
because it's me
um you know everyone's attention span oh
it's good to have a hook I think and it
wasn't even like planned it was I was
actually like let me do so much research
on this that I actually like earned the
right to make this whole special about
this and I went down there and I was
getting one made just to go through the
process just so that I could write jokes
about it and then I thought it would
just look like some shitty scarecrow and
just be something I would use like in
the promotion or on like the poster I
was really making it for the poster I
was just like oh the Whitney robot'll be
the poster because I'm like I don't know
it looked it looked very lifelike I
don't know what to do in stand-up comedy
posters like I was trying to Outsource
it so that I didn't have to just be like
looking at the camera like holding a
beach ball or something like it's just I
never know what expression to have like
you understand you know Comics you
always have to be naked female Comics
are always naked in their posters like
their first couple they're naked like
holding a microphone over their tits or
something like there's no cool way so I
was like I'll just make this she'll be
the poster it'll be funny
and then it ended up being kind of
amazing I didn't realize the technology
was so good that's crazy and I was like
let's just have her come out at the end
see what happens and then I had her come
out in La Jolla and the audience
reaction was so fucking cool because it
was like we can get laughs we can get
Applause breaks but people were like
like scared and fascinated and riveted
and I was like I like that like were you
worried that it was gonna be like an ex
machina and it could have turned on you
and killed you it still might be one I
mean I liked seeing like the different
reactions from everybody and I was like
oh I like this like comedy horror
like Vibe you know I like how it is
comedy and horror I mean it's it's such
a good marriage because it's both just
build tension and then release right 100
like that's why I think a movie like
Shawn of the Dead is so cool love so get
out like get out yeah are you worried
about this AI shit
um
yes and no robots aren't going to have
this chemistry this is this is we're
rolling well like it's here's the thing
I mean this is as of whatever the date
is August 22nd 2023 like when people are
like I'm worried Rogue AI is gonna write
scripts yeah if you're worried as gonna
write your script for you you probably
weren't writing very interesting scripts
is my guess like it but if they just
want to bang out these things that are
just going to be like the sort of
generic romance there's a lot of have
you seen suits
oh right how was that not written by AI
it's by the way there are some things
where you're like this was made 10 years
ago and it feels like it was written by
a robot he went to Harvard you know what
I mean a lot of like comedy writers in
LA are fucking dork sociopath robots
yeah and because now uh like the problem
with what's going on with script to
Comedy why it's it's so bad right now is
that it used to be like okay we're gonna
make Eight Episodes I'm sorry
we're gonna make eight seasons of a show
whether it's the office or 30 Rock or
whatever it was 24 episodes 24 episodes
and we make it for America and then we
export it all over the world right you
wait for syndication and then people go
oh this is the biggest show in America
they watch it whether they get the jokes
or not it doesn't really matter now it's
instantly all over the world so
instantly I need this joke to work in
India and China and you know the South
America and that's going to make it much
more generic much less specific you're
not going to do the jokes in the office
where it's like you're going to Chili's
and driving a PT Cruiser and you know
what I mean like that sort of like
really specific comedy goes away yeah so
they go okay this this Show's not doing
well on Hulu it's like well maybe if it
was just for America I would have but
now it's like I have to make it work all
over the world but AI kind of does that
so I think for like television it's
gonna move way we always do with South
Korea we're always like a little bit
behind it's gonna be like game shows
it's gonna be like you know regular
people
you know like doing stunts and falling
into water if they can't jump on the
lily pad or whatever these shows are
like competition shows that cost nothing
and like with who now owns like these
conglomerates owning television and
they're gonna go it's succession is
gonna be it's gonna come true they're
gonna go okay love is blind makes you
know it costs ten thousand dollars per
episode and 50 million people watch it
succession is the best show maybe like
you know on TV I love it yeah three
million people watch it it cost 20
million an episode Like It's gotta go we
don't care about art well hopefully you
can make both I mean hopefully there's a
way to you know because that's the shit
that's the shit I revisit like I just
keep re-watching Sopranos or man yeah or
shows that are like really well written
I I that's and well act and everything
about those shows were great but and
that happens in literature too it's like
you read the classics like we'll just
start re-watching the classics and stuff
like that and the stuff that's good
it'll stay good but like stuff that I
think it's background stuff people are
now consuming more and more background
stuff yeah I don't have to pay I don't
have to give my I'll fold laundry while
I do this yeah I used to have a joke
about how it would be like folding
laundry while watching like nine
straight Law and Order svus like that's
how desensitized you are do you watch
like nine rape episodes but that's like
uh but that's you know what it is and
and uh
I being at the mercy of this weird like
kind of algorithm now too I just saw Joe
list post today that his special was
getting
demonetized and buried because he said
the word continent and you're like oh my
God yeah YouTube's over I know we're so
like at the mercy of these weird
algorithms and I say this like so I'm
going to only fans TV like true like for
real yeah it's like I mean it's kind of
the only place you can kind of really do
uncensored comedy now I mean you can't
say the word vaccine on YouTube I mean
that'll have to like bleep that you know
it's like for you can't say Q Anon even
if you're saying like Q Anon isn't that
crazy and then also it's like we're
dealing with now we're talking about
okay yeah we're dealing with like robots
that can't detect sarcasm so like we're
talking about pedophilia jokes right
yeah and they can't saying like you know
like Louie had a joke back in the day
where he's like we should never rape a
woman he goes one less you wanna fucker
like you only get that's a joke if you
get that's a joke you don't get that you
don't get that if you're a robot and
we've all like by law we're supposed to
be protected by satire and parody and
all these things and like it's the
intonation of how you're saying
something and whatever so like that's
all like that Nuance has been lost like
but also like just free speech in
general like if someone's you know
YouTube has kind of become a kids
network like the the I know there's so
much money in the kids shows on YouTube
and stuff and now it's like legit
opening gifts
totally but it's also maybe you can
raise your kid to be like an unboxer on
YouTube
oh my God what is this Peppa Pig on DVD
50 000 views in 10 minutes but it's also
um like when we started on YouTube with
doing podcasts and stuff we weren't
getting Buick advertising it was like
Bluetooth and like dig pills and like
like cannabis lube and now it's like
Toyota you know so they basically go
through a transcription
like that's a goal you know like you
would want to and if they can't put
Toyota in front of your thing like what
are they doing I still I feel like we
still have like ball Clippers you know I
feel like our ads are still like do you
have good enough ball Clippers and uh I
know I just got like some crazy that's
the greatest thing about podcasts by the
way we're like we're like we this is and
this is what we have to do about Free
Speech uh sheath underwear
which by the way I do wear every day but
it is hilarious that we have these like
intense but that's stand up is like
you'll be trying to have these like this
heady premise and then you're doing it
as people are like getting fucked up on
like blue
defending free speech so China does not
take over our country brought to you by
bluetooth promo go to Whitney this is
how you have a direction I've never done
a dick pill I've never tried really I
feel like I should just try it and you
should do it out of steam I should
probably need one any day now you the
blue chew is like a it's just like a
quick chew yeah you know is the idea
that you can ejaculate and keep having
sex or that you can just get hard in the
first place well at my age I would hope
just to you know keep going but I think
at some point you know yeah or like
maybe it's just psychological because I
think like a lot of times when guys
can't perform it's just because they're
worried they won't or let's just stop
that cycle
um no I think you just fucking I don't
know I I think uh wow this got fucking
heavy
sorry
Ed I guess is like a very
I was trying to make a joke but now I
feel like this got like a serious
so tell me what no but like isn't is it
when you drink alcohol does that mess it
up for real or am I just usually jump
start actually no oh my God no that's
like better I love it when you hear
finally figure out later in life that
guys have lied to you like I was in a
writer's room once and um
and I was like oh you know what we
should do we should do a story about how
like you know how like like a lot of
guys are allergic to latex and they
can't use condoms
like all the guys were like
like doing is that how you gotten this
predicament right here
I can't Whitney I'm sorry you know how
like if guys drink too much water they
can't get erections you know how like
that's like a thing
there's got to be a lot of water but I
bet there's a point but when guys like
whiskey dick I guess I that's I think
that could kind of yeah it's more or
cocaine is bad I've never done it
neither have I yeah
that's so No One Believes me I believe
you
when I was a kid I knew a kid who just
did a shitload of and he jumped at it
like a 30-story building and landed on a
car and I was like it's not my drug you
didn't want to be awesome I mean he went
out with a bang for sure and then also I
just had like a good coach growing up
who was like who just scared me shitless
on it because he knew I liked the dragon
he's like drinking's cool but fucking
Coke fuck that I love 80s coaches oh he
was dude he had the voice of George
Carlin he was so funny he would call you
pussies he was like the funniest but uh
yeah no Coke scared me I just thought it
was like and also like that Lem bias
story is like I know it's like a freak
accident you know the basketball player
who just had a bad reaction to it and
dropped dead he was supposed to be like
Jordan's Nemesis the Celtics drafted him
and he said or something some like walls
breaking or something yeah drugs that
fuck with your heartbeat scare me also
sometimes it like has glass in it I mean
you get the wrong like I feel like we
missed our window because now with fence
yeah you know I although now this would
make a good podcast yeah we get coked up
I I was we were doing for a second live
podcast and I was like let's do every
episode I'll do a drug I've never done
like that this is not Whitney this is
not sustainable no someone who's a
drinking podcast Whitney this is a bad
idea jealous don't want composition uh
yeah we did mushrooms and then yeah
that's as far as we got there used to be
a show and I think it was at UCB where
there would be like four improv groups
and since improv's intolerable they had
to do something and uh one was on
mushrooms one was on weed one was drunk
and one did cocaine it was actually
pretty fun to watch it's pretty funny
yeah doing coke holy shit and you would
watch each of the Improv groups and then
they would all switch teams and be on
one team together it was just like a
chaotic shit show any drunk can be fun I
mean I won't do it a lot at live shows
but someone's in the crowd's loaded I'm
like fucking I'll have a few drinks and
I'll see what happens you know when it's
enough to just be like warm and fuzzy
and energized it's great but as soon as
you're like wait did I already say that
joke
I know that's my that is my nightmare I
have heard there's
I don't want to say the comic is I don't
embarrass them because it was online
like a comic that was doing drugs and
repeated the same just went into the
same bit they had already done and they
posted it might be on YouTube I think
someone else might have oh I'll tell you
afterwards and you'll be able to tell me
but my nightmare have you ever done a
joke and then you're doing
yeah and then you tell it a third time
though and they laugh again yeah just
fucking own it yeah you just keep going
no I remember it used to happen all the
time remember when you're doing those
like like zany Chicago or or St Louis
Funny Bone they'd make you do three
shows Saturday and like oh yeah three
hour long set you're gonna repeat a
fucking joke and uh yeah I mean we're
just not knowing if you've done it like
there's times you're doing it and you're
like have I done this and then it ends
up sucking because you're like a half
skittish even worse when you're like did
I do that one like no we just thought it
sucked that was just a bad joke
like just like that's my nightmare or
like I was on stage the other night and
being pregnant you're kind of just drunk
you're just clumsy you're just like it's
just weird and I do this joke where you
feel like people are nicer to you
because of that
people are prouder of me than I've ever
really adults it's like people like oh
my God like I just literally lied there
I I didn't really you didn't have this
reaction with my last special didn't
have this right anything I've actually
achieved you put a lot of work in yeah
they're this is that it's creepy how
happy people are for me weird oh yeah I
was happy I mean you know it's good I'm
happy for people too but I think I don't
know
it's it's a weird kind of attention I
don't I'm kind of really shy because we
don't because Comics are weird about
like birthdays and so we don't throw
like big anytime a comic throws a big
birthday for themselves I'm like you're
not getting enough Mark Norman I I was
like I I understand you he didn't want
to do his vows publicly in front of
people for his wedding same thing when I
was engaged I was like I'm not doing
sincere vows in front of a bunch of my
you live like live for like a you know
like you were engaged you know I mean
this is like that's intense
you're not but you'll never get married
right
I mean the one thing I'm gonna say
something which is like I'm finding that
sometimes you become what you hate so
I'm trying to not hate anything or be
too negative about something because
usually that means like it's some form
of resistance that feels too attached or
something I'll never say that I'll never
become the go go Beach murderer of the
future like anything can happen you know
I don't want to be you know but but like
like I I can see myself go in five or
ten years being like you know what would
be cool
to like get married yeah because at some
point that's going to be taboo for you
yeah because it's like no it's like
missionary being kind of hot now you
know you're kind of like you know if
he's sick just like lying down it's
gonna be like the new like New York
Magazine
marriage like just something because
there's something when people stop doing
it there's gonna be I'm gonna be like
let's do this because no one else will
do it there's something they're never
gonna stop and they're never gonna stop
but to me there's something kind of punk
rock about being like you know what we
should do
like put each other in a cage and sign a
document with the government like what
there's something kind of punk rock
about being pregnant and just going out
and doing sets I think yeah that's kind
of badass no every time I see Rose but
at the celery I'm like that's just kind
of fucking cool I see like a like a road
pick of her like you know doing the road
I just thought we think it's cool I
don't know you guys are like doing sets
pregnant I don't know it is I I I don't
I didn't when people are like oh you're
out I'm like oh am I supposed to be at
home like am I no of course not uh but
it's still cool it's still like oh
you're dealing with this and you're
still doing your thing yeah I just think
we still think about like uh
you know you just think about like okay
and you have to take some time off once
you have the baby yeah yeah that'd be
hilarious if you're like the second you
give birth you're like you know
Magooby's Comedy Club this weekend um
Magooby's Joke has five shows
but no you got it you gotta take some
time off but it's yeah it's cool is that
monkey 47 gin up there
no that is a vintage um bottle from Etsy
that's a mammary substance oh yeah but I
think I have that downstairs that's a
good gym yeah it's a really good one I
don't know I don't think I've ever had
gin in my life really yeah oh that's a
good one but wait it's ever a Negroni
maybe yeah maybe good cocktail I like
the clock say that too fast Bieber
um but getting married like I I I don't
want to slam people to do it like I I
know what it's like to want security
like I look at 30 tour dates next year
and I'm like that must be what other
people feel from like knowing they're
married you know what I mean yeah like
your career is your marriage or just
like that sounds so sad
um but no it doesn't I relate to that
but I know what it's like to really need
security and I go oh my but I saw four
divorces by the time I was 19 years old
like maybe I just like it's wired as
like this feels scary like the damage
will be worse when we break up if we do
it this way you know what I mean yeah I
just relate to that a lot because I just
also am like very career oriented and I
have every time I've had like a breakup
I just like dive head first back into
the career and I'm just like well this
will this will be my thing I mean I
still obviously this can't break my
heart yeah this won't ruin shit for me
and then of course you're like Showbiz
of course I could ruin my fucking life I
mean this is yeah also yeah if you if
you're looking for Showbiz as an
anti-rejection Place yeah then you're
fucked maybe it's like the public show
of it because I there's when you get
marry someone there's such a do you have
to see the ring you have to talk about
it you have to like set all these like
really high expectations you have to
have this big party you have to attack
I'm like if we don't tell anyone about
it and just do it
maybe that's going to take the pressure
we'll use a comedian if you do something
that's so just like pre-written you have
to at least go your own way it's almost
like this is the bit that's been done
before that's how you look at it being
done yeah it's unoriginal it's
unoriginal you're fucking yeah but it
also feels like an amount of attention
and pressure that isn't sustainable you
know what I mean and I just like I think
comedians we tend to set ourselves up
for disappointment or like manage our
expectations right this is how life is
this is what it actually is okay Barbie
came out it's good but like we're the
ones that just kind of go let's not get
carried away here with the enthusiasm
and the happiness because this is how
life really works like I think that like
the idea of getting like swept up into
this like fantasy just feels really
emotionally dangerous yeah we're
thinking it's going to solve any
problems or like fix me in any way yeah
I think that's a dangerous uh pressure
to put on a relationship too right yeah
that's what it kind of products but I
also think
it always gets like there's a honeymoon
period and then it always kind of gets a
little worse so so then you're like okay
let me sign a fucking lifetime contract
for a thing that I'm I think is maybe
peaked yeah
you know it is interesting like when
you're like okay half of all marriage is
in like if half of all planes crash like
would you ever get on a plane sure but
like probably I gotta get to Magooby's
Joke house this weekend yeah but I do
think there's something about going like
you know like friends say good
trepidations about it's like yeah but
you can
you can almost over fucking
fucking that like maybe you get married
and divorced like how much worse is
getting divorced than a breakup if
you're just gonna like take what you
left with I don't know once kids get
involved you're married anyway Nick
Griffin's got that great bit it's like a
breakup is like getting scratched by a
cat and a divorce is getting raped by a
bear
I enjoy all they used to have a joke he
was like yeah I don't know
um if you should get married or not I
just know every 10 years I have to give
away half my stuff oh it's just like
such a good when you
I have to give away half myself I think
what it is is more I've seen so much
irrational really awful behavior in a
divorce like I grew up being in a
divorce like when you go to court and
watching parents like fight over
furniture and scream at each other and
break into each other's houses taking
stuff and it just is like is this what
it brings out in people I look there's a
lot of good marriages I see people who
like have a good like those highs and
lows but there's people that have
stability and a partner I don't feel
like I've ever really had stability or
peace in a relationship for that long
yeah but then you got to look at
yourself and be like well maybe this is
what I'm seeking out this is what I'm
pursuing so you have to you know look at
your own shit too here's what's not cute
in your late 40s 50s saying I thought
you're gonna be like in your life here's
what I don't like about you no no no no
the thing that's not cute is in your
late 40s and 50s saying my boyfriend or
my girlfriend that's true that's when
it's like because you say my partner
they're like lesbian yeah yeah there's
nothing you could really say no it's
like that's when you're like my
girlfriend and you're like bitch you're
52. like huh what that would be so funny
to just say to someone that's just
embarrassing just a person checking your
ticket shut up bitch yeah like you're a
stupid bitch like that's like a rough
one I don't know I I know that in some
states like there's like benefits like
you you make save money in taxes and
stuff like that like I don't know when
the government starts paying you to do
something that's what I'm like
I just think like
you lose it's gonna sound really sad but
you lose any power once you get I almost
feel like you're kind of you're almost
like giving up
so are you saying that like this is a
really I really I realize I have a
really unhealthy outlook on
relationships I no I you're being this
is what we do and my parents I think I'm
seemingly listening to us being like Oh
that's exactly how I feel I had to do it
anyway or like I don't know like you two
are broken you're broken fucking people
I love it that's you think people are
like we're really reaching everybody I
go the other way I'm like everyone
thinks I'm a fucking lunatic uh no this
is what Comics do like we say you know
it's like I mean I made a TV show about
how scared I was to get married you know
what I mean so it's like now I'm just
trying to go like I see the benefit of
it I just don't ever want a man to stay
with me because they feel obligated
that's my nightmare like I don't ever
want to trap someone and if someone
wants to leave like go like please don't
like I never want something yeah I'm
kidding no I'm having a great time no I
really am having fun I never want
someone to feel guilty or trapped I
think if I married someone I'd be like
you can leave me whatever you want just
you know like I won't I don't want
anything of yours like don't feel
obligated I I totally yeah I think that
would make me feel more at ease because
I feel suffocated from like nothing yeah
but I also think
um
yeah I think we live these like weird
Reckless lives like on the road all the
time like think about how like cops live
and stuff there's so much excitement in
in their lives and I mean good and bad
excitement obviously like a fireman yeah
I think comedians just doing the road
where we obviously it's not as Brave as
what those do but
you know what we get attacked more I did
a pussy fart joke the other night and it
was pretty brave I hate oysters at a
comedy club there's nothing braver that
was pretty fucking great but no but but
there was something about like the rush
of what we do it is like try going to
sleep after doing a set there's a
fucking rush I mean so I think then
going back to this ordinary situation is
very
it feels almost like scripted and
predictable there's like it's like
finding someone who's not like you know
what I mean sure but don't you feel like
even if you find them there's like
scripts you have to go through like
making the check-in call well the whole
point of that is we don't have to do
that shit anymore it's like well I
married you I'll talk to you I'll see
you when I see you yeah before Mary you
live in like you know what I mean I
think it probably goes either way I
think it's like things either get
okay we don't have to do this
maintenance shit yeah to make the other
person feel secure because we already
have this thing or it gets more like
we're married now and we have to make
sure that we're working on this and you
need to be checking in because you're my
husband and now we have all these these
like rules and expectations I would hope
that it would be that we're married so
like I'll see you when I see you
I picked you you picked me we should be
able to both breathe a little bit I
think that's a big reason though people
have kids and they have like get pets I
think you need new things to bring in to
keep it exciting you go on a trip you do
I mean that that's life that's yeah it's
good to do that yeah but
um I think that a lot of people go
through life going
always looking for an upgrade they're
like I'm with this person until I like
outgrow them or an upgrade comes along
that should be part of the marital vest
my guess is probably being doing the
married part doesn't have a ton of
bearing on whether people stay together
or not I think people are going to break
up and stay together really not right
with or not you know what I mean I think
it's just a matter of I think kids a lot
of the time people stay together for
kids because I think sure but then that
can be a huge mistake right because I
think the biggest mistake you make is
going I love you I want to marry you and
then you drop a hundred thousand dollars
on a wedding and then you guys are like
we don't have any money and now all we
do is fight about the fact we don't have
money because we spent all this money on
this party to prove to everyone how in
love we were instead of just being in
love and being 100 Grand on or whatever
one night by the time it's like wedding
dresses parties all this honeymoon all
that stuff like that to me just adds
more and more pressure and I'm like how
about we that's my point this incredible
night at the wedding you go on this
honeymoon and then you just hang it's
like you built it up so I understand the
honeymoon I understand why you do it but
you're just you're going to like 10 and
then you go back home and you're what
three and a half yeah now we're just
what gonna stare at each other in Crocs
it's like yeah we're gonna watch Queen's
Gambit or something yeah if there was a
way that was just like let's just keep
it just chill I should have done a more
updated reference there guy just
Reverend the showman five years ago you
just go home and you want suits no but I
feel like because now it is the perfect
reference because you're kind of like
well I haven't watched it but we're
married now so I guess we should get
around to it we have to we have to
finish Netflix we have to watch all of
the things I'm like you just get married
and you watch a Burn Notice
so uh we get married then we start
watching Castle like what
honey I guess it's time to sit down and
finally watch Boston Legal
too
but like that's I think there's here's
what I'll say I think the opposite this
whole thing where everyone's like I'm
polyamorous and like not like that's a
whole other dysfunction yeah and what do
you think of that I think it's a total
like the Sham it's people I get to fuck
five people justifying their sex
addiction or their they don't you don't
want to be with that person and that's
totally fine and you can't be alone and
just those guys who have like five
girlfriends but then they all you know
no no you're starting a cult with people
that are insecure like no healthy person
wants to be in that and the fact that
you disguise it is this like
forward-thinking thing where I agree I'm
like it's like socially constructed that
monogamy I'm not saying you have to be
the person forever but this thing where
you need to date four people at once
like first of all get you're unemployed
like who has time for that like you know
what I mean it's like it's just um once
a guy starts quoting the animal kingdom
as a reason he should get the fuck a
bunches
and that we are supposed to scoop out
the semen and that's why I'm gonna need
to go to Coachella and fuck a bunch of
people yeah
just cheat like a normal person or like
set this person free because I feel like
whenever there's like an open
relationship one person is always affect
them into it and one person is always
like on who just went on Lexapro and is
trying to get through it
it's never like yeah we're both into
this I don't get how see I understand
like maybe women are okay with that
sometimes as a dude if I was in an open
relationship and I just saw her every
time I saw her phone vibrate I'd be like
what are you doing like what is that I'm
not secure enough at all I just I don't
has a guy ever proposed that to you I
think it's gross yeah I also think it's
gross you know what I mean um I also
value self-control I think that's hot
yeah and so someone that's just like I'm
in this thing but I've also like it's
just like go do that then cool like
um no
I think guys know better
than to step to me with some bullshit
like that I had a woman propose it to me
once and I was like do you actually want
that and she was like I think she
thought I wanted it I think a lot of I
of a lot of guys that I know are like my
girl proposed this thing and I'm like I
think it means she thinks she's gonna
lose you or is trying to get some rise
out of you or test you or something yeah
I don't buy it it's not a good idea like
do you want if you're like yeah no it's
a no I just think break up right if you
want to fuck other people just break
also what kind of person is gonna fuck
you when you have a girlfriend like what
kind of person is that not a good person
just get a sex worker I mean just truly
it would be like if you're no longer
attracting me want to stay with me and
you have these urges and you think
you're gonna act out like just do
something transactional like we can have
that conversation yeah but the idea of
like courting someone dating them and
being like well my girlfriend's at home
want to hang it's like the kind of
person you're gonna that those Plenty of
Fish you're gonna reel in it's like what
they say an AAA about um I love this one
guys no no I'm in like ACA Al-Anon which
is like the version of oh I know you're
not an AAA I don't know why I asked you
that when I it's okay yeah you're an
Al-Anon but the audience might have been
thinking it yeah so you know
um yeah so it's like the program for if
you grew up around alcohol yeah but I
know what it is they say an AAA is um
you know when someone comes in a and
it's like she's cute it's like the odds
are good but the goods are odd ooh this
is what they say you know it's like guys
it's just like you know about like if a
girl wants to date a guy with an AAA I
know but don't you always kind of want
to fuck someone you shouldn't fuck on
some level I mean not really but kind of
I mean that's what porn is yeah we're
designed I'm not supposed to fuck your
best friends I think we all every time
you scan by someone you're like would
smash wouldn't smash but it's just like
your subconscious like we're just
designed to be like yes no yes no
probably maybe like in a different world
why not you know that's how Tinder took
off that's the that's like every movie's
got a biopic like the making of like
right they're just a Blackberry they
just did flaming hot the Flaming Hot
Cheetos movie they did uh air the the
making of it that's the new genre by the
way is just capitalism that's the film
that's my favorite and then the KFC
movie with uh Mario Lopez he played
Colonel Sanders and it was yes it was it
was paid for by KFC they're gonna start
sponsoring play Chick-fil-A screeches
we're gonna move into
um uh everything it's gonna start being
like Taco Bell can you pay a million
dollars an episode for a TV show it's
starring Sam Morel and he works at Taco
Bell and they'll pay for all of it I I
like I know it's just dude Barbie is
Mattel everyone actually it's a fucking
yeah yeah yeah yeah they act like moving
original but uh you know uh I also
really quick about the polyamory I don't
know one person that's polyamorous
that's not on mushrooms oh that's an
interesting point it's not like sober
people being like this is a good idea
that rejection too has got to suck
because you're like uh you're not just
getting shut down by people you're
getting like you're a creep and I'm
shutting you down yeah but it's like the
we're all plants people like we're all
one vagina one dick we should all just
be fucking each other it's like we don't
know and those people usually aren't on
birth control it just feels like like
um it's in theory it sounds fun but it's
just no way to live it's literally like
living off Taco Bell it's like it's
great like the idea like wow that looks
great but then like you finish it and
you're like I fucking hate myself but
then you're in a situation we're like
did you have sex with someone today
because I'm not now the spontaneity of
like let's just have sex Anytime
Anyplace up against a wall in this car
it's just like wait but today did you do
you need to get tested okay exactly you
need to show me your paperwork exactly
are you one of those you have one of
those yeah I'm one of those neurotic
ladies that doesn't want to get AIDS I'm
one of those people who's like could you
if you're not gonna have sex with me
with a con could you do in the decency
of not giving me chlamydia or hepatitis
C okay let me ask you this man okay let
me ask you this do you need to actually
see the paperwork
so you wouldn't fuck someone no you
don't drive I need to see your paperwork
I know a guy can fake that I I am the
government of China when it comes to STD
tests I need to see it I need to see the
nurse that signed it really yes I need
to see it all I have gotten this far
without getting anything I'm not about
to start now I know I got them I got
this must be nice
I mean I have a lot of migraines but
nothing else because I stress out so
much about guys yeah I guess you always
have a headache so you never fuck
anybody I'm not in the mood I have a
headache you just jerk off on me and the
one time
I I got the the shot for what's the HPV
I buy some miracle I had no money in my
20s I had no health insurance I was
selling clothes at Buffalo Exchange and
I had 200 I went into the OB
um because I always thought razor burn
was herpes and I would go in and be like
what's this with this and she's like
that's not that but you should get the
hepatitis I'm sorry HPV shot what does
that stand for I don't know
um I forgot and I had to do three shots
and I didn't have health insurance it
was out of pocket 250 three times and I
would sell guys clothes that they left
at my house at Buffalo Exchange to pay
for it wow so you're good to go so I got
the HPV vaccine at least that's pretty
good yeah yeah I mean I don't know if
they could have been it was probably by
Johnson Johnson and probably it was
causing my migraines and that's where I
got my migraines The Backs injury from
the HPV job I've definitely I've been
with girls who are like but I've never
had them make me show them the papers
but yeah I'll get tested before yeah
because they're like I'm just gonna do a
relationship I'll get tested yeah
they're who is it someone or maybe it's
just a friend of mine had this Theory
he's like if a girl insists that you
wear a condom you don't have to wear a
condom because you know she always wears
uses them oh yeah if a girl tells you
not to wear a condom yeah I used to have
a bit she was like please don't wear one
and uh I said no because based on this I
don't think you'd be a good mother
that's what I said to her
you're reckless
uh but yeah I think we like forgot about
like STD I feel like people just forgot
about it and then I feel like chlamydia
a friend of mine had chlamydia and the
doctor literally didn't even he was just
like yeah everyone has it now yeah he
didn't even try to like help her it's
like the Taliban it came right back it
just everyone's got it and he like there
was there's no cure for Chlamydia is
that true what are the side effects you
have to burn it off is that is that the
one that makes it pee when you burn oh
burn when you pee every time you burn
something make sure you can't put a
sentence together that's what it says
I'm like oh fuck I can't speak
did I throw out a weird incendiary pet
peeve please
okay yeah most people I think would have
the pet peeve of like nepo baby like
that's a new thing yeah of like nepo
baby especially but was that La
especially I feel like the actors where
you're like because he's because he's
related to Copley I mean totally it's
like well so I mean yes it's annoying
it's an unfair yeah this thing we're
like so Hollywood's not fair yeah no
shit
fair you know nothing's Fair nothing's
you know what my dad for all of his like
whatever our dads were he used to always
tell me when I was a kid I mean this is
kind of bone shelling he would respect
life's not fair he drilled it into my
head in a way the go go Beach killer
would say all his victory like it's not
fair I'm sorry I mean truly like my dad
would never because I'd be like but then
my sister got this toy and I didn't he'd
be like life's not fair like he was so
aggressive about like making sure that I
knew that leaving the house and I never
expected but Hollywood is even more so
because I think familiarity is such a
big like I don't go to comedy clubs
they'd be like you can't work here
you're a girl I'd be like that makes
sense like I was never like I need to
fight for fairness yeah I mean or there
would be like a nephew or kid of someone
who'd get to go on before you and you'd
be like okay uh this sucks right now but
are they gonna be doing it in two years
we'll see yeah a lot of time they either
weren't or they didn't because I look at
people that have an advantage and I
usually feel like usually they don't
have a motivation or a skill set that I
think the people that clawed tooth and
nail for like I look at nepo people and
I I don't feel sorry for them but I'm
kind of just like oh like you don't know
how the world works or like you know
they fucking Rose to the absolute top
right that you either you either like oh
this is amazing you're like going to Paw
Patrol you're like adversity doesn't
matter I was watching a mom in an old
Colombo episode recently uh she plays
the wife of John cassavetes who's the
fucking killer in that episode yeah and
it's she looks exactly like going with
Paul show it's insane but it's also it's
like I don't think anyone gets out alive
I don't think anyone gets out alive and
it's like Gwyneth Paltrow you're like
God she's just blessed blessed born into
royalty blessed gorgeous gets these jobs
dates Brad Pitt dates Ben Affleck just
makes a candle about her pussy like the
million dollars for that and then now
people are like ah Gwyneth Paltrow Napa
and you're just like no one but no one
you know safe but that's the other thing
is public scrutiny for
decades plus right I mean when you when
when you're that
look I mean I'm sure there's some parts
of it that are a bit unhinged but I
thought like in that trial when I saw
over my she seemed like pretty nice and
fair she did but she also could have
just given a million dollars to go like
she it's like when you have that kind
but I think you have to at that level
and I've been through a very micro
version of this you have to set a
precedent you can't just sue me and I'll
sell it okay yeah I think that's what
she was doing right yeah because someone
just walked past like skied past or fell
over and was like I'm gonna sue you and
thought that she was just gonna go like
here's three million bucks to just make
this go away you know but
um like when I first moved uh the TV
show I made just came out and I there
was like Billboards around town and
stuff and I guess it's a big thing where
people when someone newly gets is on
billboards or whatever they'll just go
take you to small claims court and say
that you hit their cab like cab drivers
would do it so I get served small claims
Corp
um that's hilarious she hit my cab and
they schedule it on December 24th so
that you won't show up and usually it
just gets defaulted they make the six
thousand dollars which is like the
maximum so they they go okay this person
must have money which when you first
start doing TV and you have Billboards
like you don't necessarily you can be
known but have no money like I was like
60 Grand in debt yeah and what this
motherfucker didn't know was like I
don't have a family no one loves me
December 24th I'm at The Comedy Store
you know what I mean I was on at like
two in the morning or something so I was
like so they just expect you're not
going to show up it's downtown it's a
hassle and like even the accountant I
was working with the time was like just
don't do that it's fine like you know
whatever
I'll make the money back and I'm like no
no I'm going and I showed up and like it
was like three dudes like big belt
buckles and I like walked in and they're
like didn't expect me to show up I got
to sit through and it was like the
that really racist uh my dad used to
tell me to start growing up the racist
Briar Patch story of where they throw
the bunny in the Briar Patch it's like a
pretty racist story but you don't
realize like it's my dream to sit
through fucking small claims court on
December 24th like this is where I
there's no place I'd rather be I know
this is I'm like the guy before me
was being sued by a farmer because he
stole his bull semen in the middle of
the night like I was like oh my God I
used six grand to just the saddest Heist
of all time
and then I got to go up and represent
myself in court wow yeah and I was like
but you won yeah I was like here's where
I was that day here's uh whatever and it
was like best Christmas Eve of my life
what was like did you give him like as
you're walking out you're like I wish
you well did you did you pull like a
Gwenna I did and I was just like please
don't kill me yeah what a weird
that type of scam is pretty fucking evil
like to just I mean I guess there's
worse your mom would say cab drivers are
having a really hard time you're having
a hard time they're struggling
your mom defending United over you that
is like tells me everything oh my God
and then I can't say anything to her
because she'll be like I have a migraine
like all right you win Jesus
I'm very close with my mom nothing makes
sense yeah yeah no she's she's uh she is
awesome but yeah
Devil's Advocate too sure but when you
argue with people I mean look there's a
closeness and and that's why we bicker
all the time yeah it's not like arguing
it's bickering but it's also like as
annoying as that sounds like
it also was probably your like training
for being a comic and being able to be
quick you had someone like disagreeing
with you or like taking the opposite
side all the time so you always had to
like kind of but that's a peep of mine
too just a conversation with someone
they're like actually I'm like that
fucking sound for no reason yeah for no
reason I got another fucking pee give it
people
people I knew a guy used to go hey buddy
just the way to say buddy
it makes my like watching Men
bloody the word is fine it was the way
the guy said it watching Men greet each
other I Look Away really it's always bad
it's like you'll see two hand gestures
that are not gonna meet it's just like
you see two and you're like oh it's like
in slow motion you're like is this gonna
be a this or this or men and women
though that are friends can be that
awkward too because you don't know if
you're going for the hug with a friend
you don't know how you how you do it
yeah sometimes you get the guy who wants
to kiss the cheek and that can be weird
you know you guys will do when it's like
hey buddy what's up Chief I'm like do
you not know his name I I feel like most
you guys don't even know each other's
names quite frankly no I know that
there's always some weird nickname
boss hey boss boss is a bad one which I
feel like it's bottom five I think boss
I always feel like there's no there's no
use for the word boss ever you don't
call your boss boss never status wise I
feel like the higher power person always
calls the lower power person boss if it
seems like patronizing yeah
Buddy's a rough one too which one a
little girl ew big guy hey big guy big
guy awful little buddy like you guys are
just I don't know watching guys talk at
all it's so cringe I apologize
you probably see us turn into Dolphins
we're like hey and you're like you guys
hate each other yeah I don't know it's
all weird everyone's
I think people listening to this are
like they're awful yeah we're great wait
I don't think about any more peas am I
going too long here give me no I could
talk to you forever I just have to leave
in like 10. okay headed to Flappers to
run some new Youngs and then we're at
the Improv together later oh hell yeah
yeah all right
um and I do want to say Class Act the
Class Act tour is up and cracking oh
you're here in LA tomorrow night yeah I
was sick and then Calgary Bethlehem that
one's sold out I think but yeah these
are amazing City Chicago Phoenix
Pittsburgh Cleveland Columbus Cincinnati
Annapolis New York City oh going to
Australia second time in uh Vegas this
year I was like fuck I kind of I kind of
like Vegas I did the Mirage last time
this time I'm doing uh the win nice but
yeah big ones are like Chicago Theater
uh I've never headlined and then uh
amazing MSG theater in New York uh the
fourth huge Toronto is a big one too I
don't it's Toronto do they not oh they
were Symphony No it's like a Meridian
Hall I think in Toronto that's a big one
Toronto's amazing the crowds are fucking
love it yeah Cleveland Columbus
Cincinnati India everywhere yes uh
Pittsburgh Phoenix but uh yeah no the
road is the fucking best it's the best
baseball comedy it's like the best
comedy right now is my favorite it's
ever been I don't know if it's we're
also the best we've ever been at comedy
but it's like people are so ready to
come out and laugh and like I think that
doing podcasts or YouTube or whatever
like we found comedy fans it's not just
people like stumbling in and being like
I'm here to see comedy tonight it's like
people that like love they have to make
an effort I heard Chris Rock said an
awesome thing to me once uh just like we
which happened to me in the same Hotel
in St Louis and it was like the first
time I was playing theaters and he's
just fucking so quick like he just
anything he has a concise way of saying
yeah in a smart way yeah it's like he's
been thinking about it for 30 years it
happened yesterday I know he's just the
best but he said uh I said to him like
man I don't know people I've been doing
clubs for so long and and theaters
there's just so much better behaved and
he goes velvet seats
and I was like holy shit that's true
that's probably part of it it's just you
feel classier when you're sitting in a
velvet scene perfect
Chris Rock
he's good God damn it the best yeah all
right all right you're awesome thanks
for your time you are it's fun yeah you
got to come back on ours when you're I
would love it
yeah yeah I'm allowed to have a couple
guys the wine while pregnant really yes
that is an invitation come watch me on
Sam and Mark's podcast uh make the video
that we'll make sure I lose custody of
my child in 10 years I and these
awkwardly um love you guys Sam um just
samuel.com yeah Class Act tour I'm so
jealous of that title no red elephants
[Music]
all right
[Applause]